[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
round four of the Winter Classic here in
st. Louis
in Group A Jeffrey Zhang could not
convert against Sam seve on the two
youngest players in the section played
to a surprising draw in B jaco bein
called it a day when Timur garea
promoted to a queen with his first win
can the number two seed still prove his
relevance coverage of round five starts
now 20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
calm presents the second annual winter
chess classic well if the World Chess
Championship is what the world is
watching well hopefully this is what
they're gonna be watching in a few
moments when the world championship game
is over here in st. Louis come on into
the studio it's Studio B two floors
beneath the world-famous tournament hall
hello chess fans I'm Ben Simon joined as
always by Grandmaster in-residence
Jessie cry Jessie okay
the lead should be about the Winter
Classic right but the World Championship
is going on right now what are your
thoughts on the game well you know
there's been a bruja down here at the
Chess Club because on one side you got
the commentators the the you know doing
the match and guys like Maurice is
saying this is a terrible game poorly
played and I we almost got into blows
down here oh yeah I saw it got into
blows because I was like that was a
beautiful game that Magnus put together
to get the position he got and just the
fact that he took his pedal off the gas
doesn't mean it was a terrible game it
was a beautiful game I thought and it's
still going on I think Magnus will will
try to work this for at least another
hour where again maurice disagrees with
me but if you get bored over there you
come watch us right you got some
exciting games hey it's it's 2018 open
all the windows you can right yeah what
is your assessment do you think that
this is petering out to a draw though
after an hour or so I mean it's
technically a draw
but I know that in positions like this I
would try forever and I know Magnus is
even worse than me he'll play a drawn
position till blue in the face you know
and it could go another hundred moves
when surprise me and it's about
psychology too about the willingness to
grind your opponent yeah their plane is
in london we're here in st. louis and
this is without a doubt the busiest day
in US chess champs calm history and a
little website maybe we'll have to
revamp it soon it's getting the workout
today let's take a look at our group a
standings after four rounds we're at the
midway point here and we've been talking
a lot about jeffrey zhang and today
we're gonna take a closer profile at
Quesada who is his equal so far
numerically tied for first at the top
what are your thoughts on a group a at
this juncture well a little while ago it
seemed like maybe Jeffrey was gonna have
to defend a worse end game but now I
think he's just absolutely fine and I
honestly will take a look in I'm not
sure what's going on and he's playing
Moda left one of the greatest attacking
players of all time
and then the game will take a closer
look at is moku me and against casada
and of course we haven't talked about
casada he's in tied to the lead with
jeffrey so this this tournaments still
very you know wide open in terms of what
can happen but from what I can see
Jeffrey is not letting off the gas even
if he's getting a couple draws and
actually I'll do an update for us
yesterday I really enjoyed how he played
against Sam and Sam you know as we left
the show I said if he has any chance
it's gonna be active counter play he was
down upon then and that's exactly what
happened yeah and let's take a look at
Group B standing is now in Group E we do
have a clear leader but it's not by much
just a half-point Lukas van forest we're
halfway through guys I mean van forest
has been consistent in his performance
but we'll see if we can take it all the
way Jessie your thoughts well we're
gonna have our key matchup today is van
force against Theodore if you remember
Theodore was the guy who sacrificed like
a madman
one of brilliancy against peril Stein
earlier we had him here in the studio
and here you know Lucas fen Forrest is
proving that he's also a madman he's
just sacked his Queen and so we're gonna
take a look at that I'd uh honestly I I
think I like White's position with the
Queen but you know there might be
differences of opinion there all right
if you're just joining us for the first
time remember us chess champs is where
you want to go us chess champs calm to
see the live games go to winter chess
classic drop it down and click live
because the world championships going on
you have to take that one extra step
today but we're glad that you're with us
the tournament format is as follows we
are looking at 210 player around Robin
fields the time control is classical but
not as long as the world championship
match 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
plus 30 minutes for the remainder of the
game
there is a 30-second increment from move
number one so players are always
required to take notation and no one can
agree to a draw before blacks thirtieth
move to encourage fighting chess here's
the schedule every day we are on the air
at 3:30 p.m. but the games start two and
a half hours earlier at 1:00 p.m.
Central Time the final day next Tuesday
everything begins early because we will
have playoffs if there is a tie for
first place and you definitely wouldn't
want to miss that all along the way
please join us on YouTube twitch watch
the games on ly chess I'm pretty sure
we're on there today and also hashtag
winter chess classic to join the
conversation I do have the chat window
of YouTube open it seems all of the
crazy rhetoric is in the World
Championship room so maybe they'll be
very civil today but send your questions
our way if you desire we might just ask
them on the air and answer them here are
the pairings for round number 5 group a
action Sam Semyon vs. Krishna and SAS
akhirin alexander multi-levels Jeffrey
Zhang ray Robson versus Alexander
Shimano
Miro vs. daro spirits and as we said our
key matchup in group a UNESCO Quesada
vs. Franta Nell Quyen and
let's give Quesada a little bit of lip
service here and let's take a look at
this game cuz we really haven't looked
at too much of his game so far
absolutely and one thing actually it
might be interesting to talk about is
this position happened in the World
Championship today and it also happened
in casados game today
and you know one interesting thing about
Carlson and everybody else is we there's
been this general trend which feels to a
lot of people including myself to be
boring where everybody's playing a 45
and I expect to see some e45 in the
World Championship and what as well but
it's so refreshing to return to the old
fighting opening the Sicilian and so
this is what we got also in the World
Championship and there's a lot of
speculation as to what Magnus was gonna
do against the open people are saying
shavasana go I don't know but that
sounds like a good bet so this is his
surprise opening and one reason I really
want to bring it up is that you know
that theory for a 45 has exploded so
much after Magnus started playing a 5
was such a such success and E for the
slow e for both developed by Magnus that
if Magnus started playing something else
it would be very refreshing for chess
and not only that I think in this game
both Magnus's team and fabi's team will
definitely look at this game it's just a
different approach for white than the
normal Bishop takes c6 after g6 this is
what Bobby played and that's been the
traditional move for a long time and at
first it I'll say just a little history
you know 20 years ago and everyone
thought that move was absurd but now
it's become kind of very fashionable
anyways let's look at what casada did he
just plays this Bishop back
and looks at the f7 pawn so a completely
different approach than taking on c6 and
one thing I want to mention that I
personally I find interesting is you
know I've been hanging out a little bit
with moku Mian and milk oomiya a lot is
training with Aronian and has a lot of
interesting opening ideas through him
but also interesting to me is these top
players what things I've discovered is
like no cumin they are when I was you
know when I had to study I have my
computer open and maybe stock fish
running on my computer though I don't
like using the the stock fish too much
myself now that's being exported to a
cloud and so on the cloud someone else
is running a computer for them right so
you're getting a supercomputer action
going for you instead of your regular
computer and that's one of the reasons
when you look at mokume ian's games this
tournament loads of interesting ideas
what I think now ku means playing for
here with h6 is a very nice system that
Aronian does almost all the time within
these kinds of things which is to castle
put the King on h7 and look to play f5
alright let's look at how it went before
nakooma is not interested in taking that
thing and this position arises where I
think it's solid for both sides but it's
still it's still gonna run into a mess
and so this is our current position and
we'll come back to it it looks equal ish
but it's definitely a position where the
better side I think is gonna have
chances all right very well I think we
should proceed to the Queen sacrifice
let's do it let's take a look at the
games going on right now in Group B
these are all viewable live at us chess
champs calm as Ivan Adri a.cian versus
Aaron Jaco bien JJ a lemur on D vs.
Robbie kabloosh melee team are garea
versus Eugene peril Stein Victor
mikhalev ski versus Joel Benjamin and
the sacrifice game are team
Nicolas theodoro versus Lucas van forest
I'm curious Jessi in fan forest
sacrifice paid off and we're about to
find out I it really resulted from a
little bit of desperation
by the way the you know Theodora is a
very aggressive player and doesn't mind
taking risks in this system it's fine
it's a thing that Kasparov invented
years ago there's a number of different
ways black can play against it and of
course then forest plays a very
aggressive pawn snatch early in the
opening and I thought black got a
totally reasonable position and here I'm
gonna be critical this is where I think
the problems for van forest started
coming up in general this Bishop never
really wants the pawn on e4 anyway
he just wants it out of the way so this
take I'm very critical of because it
gives the bishop now much more scope and
it allows for ideas like Knight d4
Knight c6 so I'm critical of that and
instead I think like that's a queen EA
or maybe some queen somewhere else just
so that you can leave the tension and
it's very hard for white to actually do
anything you're afraid of de okay let's
go back takes takes Knight B 395 and now
the threat is d6 is an important threat
we're gonna see Bishop c5 Bishop g5 and
I don't know if you planned them as the
trap here I mean that the Queen sac but
it's kind of interesting so rook e8 and
now one way to interpret what's going on
is that on Knight g4 that maybe blacks
intention was to play Bishop e7 there's
a problem with Bishop e7 though then d6
comes and you're toast because the
bishops hang both bishops are having
so in this position Theodorus said well
you know what let's take let's give up
my queen and I'm gonna claim that I have
peace activity I have a pawn and my
pressure on f2 is something special
I don't yeah it doesn't feel right to me
but that's what he did and white played
an attempt of tempted to just refute him
with and it looks correct d6 you gotta
take snip and here's a big problem for
black because if I am able to recapture
on g2 then the game's gonna be over
however let's take a closer look at this
right let's imagine rip d1 if rook c8
will play King g2 and it looks okay for
us okay and then let's imagine Bishop b7
to hold the point I guess
rook d8 is the problem
it's still not over for though because
there's some kind of King f8 and maybe
there's then Queen h7 this is
complicated alligator very it looks
pretty uneasy for black well what about
for white he just like he's down after
we lose the bishop on g2 we're down a
bunch of stuff so this attempt with d6
you know obviously White had other moves
this is a very theodoro way of doing
things where you know I was an
interesting thing about that peril Stein
game he's he's okay with starting some
fireworks without knowing exactly where
they're going yet which is a which is
you know can be a very good practical
thing when I'm trying to say is these
things that he does are often intuitive
and not necessarily totally thought-out
which you know fine it's the way of
playing this I'm not sure I'm not sure
it's gonna work out but the current
position on the board is this one here
and black is now considering what is
wrong he's asking himself what is wrong
with Bishop b7 and let's put it on the
board one more time
notice bishop f2 is kind of a real thing
I don't know if I would want to see a
bishop b7 has been played and and
theodoro needs to prove that he can
start some stuff because those minor
pieces are very angry and notice also
that Knight d4 is coming soon so white
needs to prove something immediately
before things go wrong there's been so
few moves that have just been played
okay yeah d8 and here they're you know
this is what I mean by not exactly me
saying that he doesn't know exactly how
it's gonna go is not really it not meant
at all like an insult it's just that
imagine this position there was King f8
there was Knight f6
and the move played Brooke f8 you it's
very hard to see all of those right
and more more than anything I think
white is claiming that that pawn will
eventually win him a piece but notice if
he wins that wins apiece say the Bishop
on b7 well the game is very much still
gonna keep going on we've got an attack
against the white king and the night is
coming to d4 or d2 at some point so huh
yeah I think from Van Voorhis
perspective having really sacrificed a
queen in a position where you know
things probably weren't going that well
this is a good outcome so we'll keep an
eye on this game I absolutely Queeny for
I was told Queen e4 was just played yep
there there it is Queenie for yeah and
black has several moves but not that
many minutes to think about it move 23
and Queenie for a very whoa very spicy
move very spicy let me just point out
that if Bishop b7 c8 is unfortunate
indeed and even here there's some tricks
that I'm not totally sure I guess let's
let's let's assume that there's enough
here for black but even I mean for white
but even like look at this Bishop f2
King here oh there's some there's some
open questions here like if Bishop b3
you can't take rook d3 because the Queen
if King G - may I guess the intention is
to hide oh no you and I might you can
take any for excuse me
so Queenie for this is in the theodora
style this is what this kid is so fun to
watch of he's hitting the knight is
there a way out I suspect there's more
than one move here for black honestly
now let's imagine Bishop c8 if nothing
else
what white could then do is rook c8 rook
c8 Queen d7 right so that's the easy way
out after Bishop c8 is there anything
else that we could consider
it feels real dangerous to me for like
this is definitely where black wants to
take a moment and he does play Bishop f2
okay so that is going to force King f1
and now we're going to ask a simple
question is there a shot here it feels
like there should be a shot
so notice that on Knight d2 rook takes
out then I could take your queen so you
don't want that but I guess the problem
is if you just go Knight d2 and then
King e2 I still don't know where the
maid is but look no it's simpler than
that your Queens hanging buddy right
here Queens hanging buddy
so rip takes is gonna be forced Bishop
takes comes and I think that's the end
of the story isn't it I think that's the
end of the story
yeah I think so
rook d8 Bishop b7 and you need some kind
of magic but it doesn't look good here
down a lot of pieces you've done a lot
of pieces 95 could be a trick and you
just got to make sure you don't get
wasted with like 97 so maybe Bishop c5
okay that's spicy and you know it's
funny after the game with Theodore
imperil Stein I had an argument with
peril Stein because I thought Theodore
played so well that he deserved to win
and that peril Stein but to lose for
losing these light squares with Knight
takes g6 and peril Stein on the other
hand was just so upset that the theodoro
got away with what he called the bluff
right that he played some move and
didn't actually know what was going on
right and what it looks like at the
moment is that theodoros Bluff is
getting called this time that he played
this thing with d6 in dc-7 trying to
refute this position where I think he
was better let's go back to here where
is better in this position he has a
number of different moves
he doesn't have to lose his mind with d6
he's so quick he's the one with the
advantage and this bishop is not great
right now
it's the one piece of blacks that isn't
working so d6 even from a positional
standpoint is a little bit funny
Jesse we do have our first result of the
tournament okay in group a multi live
and Jong have drawn their game right
that was to be expected yeah and let's
take a quick look at that because you
knows very tense
efore a5 struggle with one of these
openings that we're gonna see more of
and I suspect we're gonna see at least
one game with this in the World
Championship and as I mentioned before
moto left has a very strong attacking
player and here he's going to steal
Zhang's Bishop and claims he has an
advance
Jean plays a move here that if I was a
coach I would have said no that's a
mistake yeah he don't play d vive their
friend but he did and he's playing for
activity and look at that move Queen
takes e4 maybe a bit much another move
actually that I just because I am a
lover of activity I thought rook-a for
was interesting but we get this
situation and Jean loses the exchange
was it intentional let's imagine it was
maybe he missed it though so we get this
position and at first I was a little
concerned for Jeffrey but the problem is
it takes really too long for white to
get in and then if you have to babysit
the c2 pawn with rook F to the activity
with Knight d4 and I b4 is gonna come
too fast so you know after this kind of
business where the knight can disrupt
the coordination of the black or the
white rose right if they can't double on
the seventh ring a draw was a Greek so
Geoffrey continues to play very strong
and another admirable game so I'm he's
still gonna be in the lead unless casada
win so let's check in on that and as I
predicted our medians let me just say
this in my experience there means they
can't just hold the position they got to
spice it up I got it spice it up
sometimes it's a mistake to spice it up
but it always makes the game more
interesting when we left we were
somewhere around here and
right this happen Queen see one rookie
six f5 so let's talk about it as I
mentioned before Levon Aronian who is
mokume Ian's teammate in Armenia in the
national team has championed a lot--it's
jump back over to the band for escape a
quick because that game has it may have
just ended actually that was the big
sacrifice game right and it didn't look
like it's good yeah Ben Forrest did not
go oh what happened did I I must have
missed something
hold on Bishop f2 kingi to Bishop a 494
force missed whatever it was I missed
because I missed it what that the king
could go to g2 Wow because the c8 square
is running black out of the c8 square
hey Theodora is on fire so one
interesting thing I will say as a chess
fan is it's sometimes interesting when
you're wrong you look at something and
what you thought you had a kind of a
sense of what was going on and then you
took out your crystal ball you know and
you rubbed it a little bit gave you the
wrong end we'll see that's just the
thing we're not using a crystal ball
isn't that the part of the magic in your
opinion of not using it an engine for a
live analysis I mean assuming that the
engine would spit out white's winning
yeah well right and because an engine
well the thing is right it's like the
engine doesn't understand what you're
going through at the board right and so
what I'm trying to do with the analysis
is show kind of what people are thinking
and honestly I think van forest was
probably thinking what I was thinking
when he played Bishop f2 he's and a
little bit of time pressure I'm not sure
that's the only thing he's got after
queenie 424 is a beautiful move and
arguably that is what Theodora saw all
the way back if we want to give him
really a lot of credit maybe we'll get
him in here
get him in here actually the the d6
we'll ask him if he saw Queenie for when
he played d6 because that's kind of a
big critical move for that that would be
truly impressive right if he was able to
Z Queenie for when he played d6 Bishop
takes king g2 and the bishop on b7 you
simply run out of town there's nothing
you can do I'm going to take that bishop
mmm okay so beautiful game let's return
to Mel cumin and maybe we'll get
Theodora in here it's a really
interesting business where are we okay
Sodom l qu Mian group a and so what I
was gonna say is Aronian been doing this
f5 thing for years in a lot of slightly
similar positions but the difference
here was that white did this b4 thing to
trade the b4 pawn really for the D pawn
so if it were a pawn on d6 black would
feel a lot more happy about this but
what White's doing now is he is
body-slamming the pawn on e5 and it's
kind of the thing that now he's going to
have to babysit after the move f5 and
the question arises is what benefit did
Mel kuhnian get out of playing f5 it's a
little bit unclear but I've been hooked
before let me just say if you were a
Kings Indian player you could dream
about playing f5f for Jesse we do have
Nikolas theodoro right outside our
studio so we're gonna get him in here
for that interview cool I'll just keep
talking about this and then we'll get
him in here so one thing you would do
here in a position like this is you
could dream about f5f or in some kind of
attack but here without your light
square bishop it seems really hard to
imagine and of course f4 would make the
bishop on g7 incredibly bad so we're
waiting I guess to see what mokume Ian's
intentions are and I expect to maybe a
simple move like rook a1
and you know the standard plan let's
call it that would be to play things
like rookie 2 and rookie 1 to demand
that black show us his cards with the e5
pawn makes some kind of commitment I
think we want him to play f4 so maybe a
small edge now for casada and of course
if casada wins that would put him over
the top while we're waiting let's oh
here he comes
let's just look at one more game we're
setting up and that is raised game which
has also been a total mess but I believe
in raised position restarted poorly of
course but I think he's making a
comeback conceivably in this game I like
the position a lot ok we are here now
with the famous Greek who has done it
again played a very nice attacking game
and we're gonna ask him a couple
questions about this so yeah here we are
before the board up happy to have you
back you're the first person to make it
in here twice that's amazing looks like
alright
any words about this opening I think
black should be fine many different ways
but I wanted to try to see what happens
okay it's I think it's it fits your
style right it's gonna be a fluid game
that's what I thought and then forest is
not a guy to you know not take up the
challenge so here he does he he takes a
pawn and I I've had kind of only put it
this way I've had similar positions in
in the Catalan and it always makes me
nervous at the pawns on e4
because then my bishop feels unhappy I'm
g2 right that's true but what else can
you do right what else can you do
so I was I thought blacks position was
basically fine here I don't know I think
a 9 c4 should be an interesting option
Knight c4 and 934 Knight g4 yeah yeah
yeah it felt you just plagued with a
plan here though right of stuff yeah b5
was my preparation actually oh yeah this
is a prep okay I have an important
question for you I fell that black
taking on d5 was wrong yeah I think if I
remember correctly Queen yeah it is
correct
sure right because you know by struggle
and the reason I talked about my
prejudice about the e4 pawn is the
second he takes then your Bishop on g2
all of a sudden has a lot going on
yes and then you can dream about Knight
d4 and all the other usual tricks yeah
so I thought this was maybe the
beginning of some grief for vent force
I'd stay fine I thought he thinks yeah
okay yeah now it's gonna start getting
interesting after that yeah yeah yeah it
was this funny thing where I don't well
maybe we could ask him later but I felt
like maybe on Bishop c5 Bishop g5 rook
e8 that he maybe this isn't correct that
when you played here that maybe his
first instinct was Bishop e7 but then
you just have d6 yeah and then you're
winning so it was kind of weird like he
played rook e8 allowed Knight g4 and
then he just took it I don't know if he
missed 94 but he couldn't find them good
move here for block for instance after a
night before I can simply play queen bee
wrong mm-hmm maybe Bishop c8 that's
probably the best move I can take on
with the night right yeah yeah and then
honestly you have a choice of where to
put the thing h4h I don't even play me
so much for today
yeah yeah so you know I thought maybe
you're a little bit better or something
I don't mean Pleasant for white but not
over okay
were you surprised when he did this I
thought he might do
stealing was quite surprising right okay
now my big question I want to know how
far you saw when you played e6 I saw
until the very end and the King do but
of course there were many other lines so
you saw Queenie for when you did yeah
very impressive I mean very best you can
play off of the six you can play c6
mm-hmm but right now of course yeah he
play C six then you can play d6 with a
with a good conscience
yes but the pond might become weak well
it's already wheat yeah this was
interesting because you have other you
can play it was interesting to me
because you can play so many other
different moves and unless you have
Queenie for it looked like he was doing
pretty well of course one should be
better about it's not so easy right I
mean I was I mean he's got a lot of
firepower coming yeah yeah yeah
okay so let's show this to the fans
again d6 takes takes so if you play
something like rook c8 I guess you just
play King g2 and be happy about life
yeah so snip-snip and this is only real
chances they should be safe and like you
can play Bishop HC but I okay yeah let's
look at Bishop age three
other could be id8 and I think might
have six and the bummer for him is he
never has even though he has all these
beautiful miners in front of your king
he never can mate you yeah you were
saying night of six the a night of six
makes sense to feel it I think I can lay
94-94 I thought you were gonna say
Queenie for my birthday that's your
favorite movie
yeah 94 mate is more sober yeah
Queenie for I guess he could play King
f8 or something oh yeah you should be
reading quad 94 is more sensing yeah
okay good so Bishop e7 rook d8 and here
well I guess one of the reasons it was
impressive to me is that it seemed to me
like he had various moves here too like
it wasn't just rook f8 he could have you
had to figure that one out he had to
figure that one out
right know so I said let me be able to
walk through that Knight f6 and yeah I
can play Queen f5 45 looks good yeah
yeah or even 94 might be interesting
yeah uh-huh let's just point out that
ubiquitous queenie for here i guess you
could yeah you might have been able to
you're probably good to just played see
a queen there too yeah okay yes a knight
f6 and then the other one was King f8
that one might be it because if nothing
else you could play rookie you know the
Queen a five again I can't stay pretty
grainy fall I think Queenie for sure
yeah that's good
so very nice game yeah very nice game
thank you
who are you so you've got your plus plus
one plus one and who you playing
tomorrow um every spoon you okay great
well good luck I really I've really
enjoyed both the games you played you
got a like a a collection for that book
you know the best games coming up and
yeah hope to see you soon we're gonna go
to a little commercial break now
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error instead boogie through the
city and discover the music that gave
the Blues their name at the National
Blues Museum Broadway Oyster Bar or even
the legendary Blueberry Hill so whether
you love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Lou is always
exploring
hello chess fans welcome back to
coverage of round five of the 2018
Winter chess classic my name is Ben
Simon and I'm joined by Grandmaster in
residence Jesse cry
Jesse during the break first of all we
want to welcome everybody who was just
on the world chess championship feed
over to the winter chess classic welcome
to the party
this is where it's at of this worth it
so big news out of the match Jesse yeah
Bobby held and Magnus fan is definitely
gonna be disappointed because it was a
big chance and I really feel like it's a
big moment because if Magnus had won oh
man it would have been really rough to
lose Game one with white and now the
match will simply go on and Magnus I
think it's a good definitely even though
Bobby got outplayed in the early part of
the game
I don't feel too bad about it because it
was definitely a thing that rose out of
Magnus's preparation and understanding
of the position that he got outplayed so
I don't think Bobby should feel bad
about that part and going forward you
know he can feel of the confidence that
oh man Magnus didn't execute when it was
time and so we get right you know my
chances for Fabi went up a little bit
let's put it that way well I know that
the tensions here at the st. Louis chess
club were were pretty high earlier today
and everyone was kind of off you know
but okay
draw it starts over tomorrow definitely
not a boring draw either right I mean
yeah and also about the game a lot of
people you know
good game bad game technical oh we were
having I was saying we were having a
fist fight me and Maurice here he was
talking so much smack and I was like
Maurice these people played some good
moves I honestly like if Magnus had won
this game as he probably should have the
maneuvering that he did to get the
better position and the pawn sacrifice
with Knight f8 I mean it still should go
down to some very impressive chess yeah
sure it was a fun game it was a
beautiful game as far as the Winter
Classic goes let's dance around all
right and take a little bit of a glance
at each game so do you have anything you
want to look at first I have let's just
roll through the games and the a section
in front of us I've got Samuel Savion
against saucy and Samuel has been doing
strange openings every single game it's
clearly part of a strategy to not play
theoretical lines and in this game he
played a Sicilian with Queen takes d4
and then b3 so very odd business where I
don't know roughly equal position
happened and then we're gonna dance when
do the dance with saucy and saucy is
gonna love this position here opening up
the bishop and everything and so you
know Samuel has to spend a lot of time
figuring this out and to me it looks
like blacks should be better in this
position well for sure we got the
weekend pawn on d3 and of course we have
the two bishops so right away saucy got
a very nice position out of the opening
and the game though is going to progress
and it's hard to prove these kinds of
positions but the point right now is
that the knight is going to be kicked
away and the bishops are gonna start
they're gonna start getting angry here
at some point g5 is what I expect for
black to open things up on the Kings
side and hopefully get an initiative for
the bishop
so in a nice game for saucy Geoffrey's
wrong drew drew and then in the game
ropes and Shimano it looks like ropes
ins gonna finally break the curse here
and come to have a much better position
well should win this game against
Shimano where I think he played a really
great game let me show you this crazy
position f4 look at all those points
spots and she want to play BAM e5 so a
very tight game and I'm sure some
mistakes were made but definitely ray
played several good moves and one I'll
draw your attention to is after getting
his knight pushed all the way back here
in this tension tense position after
Queen a5 let's look at the sequence he
did Knight d2 takes takes and Shimano
says I want your knight and Ray says you
can have it very nice Bishop a4 snip
snip snip snip and white is better and
let's ask why it's because the bishop
will now come to a4 and make it hard for
the knight on b8 to move so this is the
position we got and there it is d6 in
addition to the night we want to push
our pawn there he does so we get our
Queen and look at that a nice positional
sacrifice where white is down a pawn but
has all the advantages and in particular
the knight on b8 is dominated so Shobana
sacked the exchange and that leaves us
to where we are now where I think yeah
after a move I assume like rook d5 we
should be doing quite well I shouldn't
say we it's actually pay folks today
would be doing quite well all right we
have another result a mural versus daro
that game is a draw right and so ever
since mural lost in round 1 he's been
continuing to play very solid chess
and I think he's drawn every game since
then and that game itself was kind of
let's call it a game work mode Aleph was
just cranking a very small advantage
against me Rose Petrov and here Mero is
just happy to hold and I think Mero
story would be the story of mini an old
man where you come back and you face the
young bucks and really you're just
trying to hold your own you're trying
not to get wasted off the board and
that's what he did in this game in our
casada game we had this interesting
question let's just say it was
interesting for me about why f5 was
played and here g3 is kind of curious
because it's going to encourage black to
play f4 because at least the pawn on f4
will have some dynamic tension and he
does it now on the surface it seems to
me like White's position is preferable
because his structure is so good and the
pawns on e5 & b6 are weak however black
is going to dream of at least starting
some drama on the kingside with moves
like g5 and maybe at some point in f3
maybe at some point and opening on the F
file so I think White's better but
there's definitely practical chances
from alchimia this is the kind of game
is very hard to win as white even though
it's easy to say that white should be
better yeah I expect to when we get in a
tight pressure like this they got 14
moose to make with both around 6 minutes
to play both sides will make mistakes
that's why I don't like it when Maurice
starts saying stuff about Magnus and
fabbi when they get to the time pressure
phase and they start making what it
seems to him is obviously bad moves
there's a lot of pressure there and if
you look at any game whether it's a
super GM or just some punk more mistake
it's gonna mistakes are gonna be made at
this phase of the game it's something
when you review your own games and you
train it's something you should just be
aware of it'll help you become you know
where - the fact that even you're
playing some strong opponent that they
will
new chances right when we get to the
hectic phase of the game Jesse and next
game I'd like to look at yes over in
Group B sure Robby Kepler's really has
devastatingly pinned a bishop to JJ a
lemur on D let's see if JJ is in trouble
here
you know Catholic Billy he's doing
terribly here in the tournament but I
will say this every game he's played has
been a huge fighting battle and he's
friends as far as I can tell with his
the the van forest of the Van Voorhis
chess family and those two guys are
there they're fighters they like the
crazy positions and that's what we have
in front of us here my guess is that the
bishop should be able to survive
just because G if G six ever comes then
Queen e5 but are their mates coming you
know is mate coming with rook d3 or
something that might well be so it's
less the bishop I'm consuela I'm
concerned about the bishop too but I'm
also worried about our friend mr. mate
this is rook d3 preferable to you over
Queen d3 just for Styles sake well I
mean it's it's this is truly one where
we need to be aware I'm sure black is
analyzing it so queen g4 King g4 we need
a good move here
that's yeah we need a good move I don't
know what it is but we might have it
that's so that's the problem and on rook
d3 I assume we're looking at just a very
similar thing with King g4 so it smells
like meat but it's not necessarily mate
and like I said g6 queen bee v we're
gonna get out of it if nothing else if
nothing else we're gonna be able to do
this kind of little dance okay
it smells like mate though I don't see
it I don't see it for black so in that
case well maybe that pin is it as
devastating as I originally thought it
well maybe there okay so you know it's
not over at all like for example on King
g8 notice there's well you could check
actually no no you can't check there cuz
I'm just gonna take your queen you could
play rook f4 but there's kind of an
interesting situation where maybe you
could try to find something after a
rogue f4 yeah it would not surprise me
if black found something here though
yeah so can we take a look at the old
guys yes I know you're dying to I love
the old guy trippy halusky and joel
Benjamin there in time pressure and I
want to show one position that happened
look at this tension here earlier whoa
that's a big Mick kind of tension you
asked me what's going on there that's a
lot of pawns that's a lot of pause I
really want to tackle this yeah I'm not
gonna tackle it I just wanted to show
you it so let's take a look at how this
all went down oh my god what a mess what
Oh
look at that nice g6o hold on here what
why
because Knight d6 is gonna come after
okay okay but Benjamin says no I'm with
a d3 I'm gonna snip oh my god what CD 98
rook F EA so the bummer was that the
knight on EA is touching the bishop
so it has Knight f6 as a threat Bishop
e7 snip Bishop a6 so all of a sudden
it's kind of sort of mellowed out into
an opposite color Bishop ending or you
could call it a middle game if you want
but the problem is our friend on d2
looks very powerful so let's see if big
mech have a chance to salvage this rook
D 8 B 1 D 2 H 4 King g7 and it's a funny
thing here where black really would like
to get his Bishop to this diagonal here
to both protect the pawn at the touch he
won so the cleverness of rook b1 is
you're gonna have to sit there with the
rook so that this pawn will continue to
guard that c3 square so the bishop can't
come down so rook FD one rookie for M
this looks this looks great for black
should be winning but big mech is very
tough to beat I'll say this one thing
just as a general note on bishops of
opposite color positions there's this
common misconception that their draws
but that is definitely not true
especially in a position like this
especially in a position where it's
there are other pieces besides the
bishops because in a position like this
it's black is the only one who really
controls the dark squares and white is
just doing the light squares
and in position like this is very
important because white will never have
enough juice on the dark squares to
really challenge D to effectively it's
there for life
same thing with E 1 square so all white
can do is really hope to get a blockade
on the light squares and if black it it
develops an initiative on the dark
squares there's just going to be nothing
for white to defend and as with the Fabi
game in a position like this with little
time left we can guarantee that both
sides will be making mistakes all right
some moves actually been played let's
check it out
bishop f1 rook b4 very nice and what
does jewel doing he's saying please move
the beep on so that I can put my bishop
on c3 big Mick says ok you got me but
I'm gonna trap your rook so now it's
getting hot big Mick so you see how
these things go you you fight for a
positional advantage and white has to
give you give it to you but in return
he's giving getting something himself so
as Victor just paralyzed at this point I
mean that rook in the corner looks
really bad
well it's Joel you mean this rook here
I'm b4 well what what about the what
about the b1 rook the Iran works
paralyzed to the the the pressing
question though I think for Joel is what
are you gonna do about a3
that's that's prophecy
that's problem it's on the board and a B
5 happened and this is very hard to
calculate in time pressure a3 and here's
the drama that is unfortunate for Joel
is it if he could take this bishop and
then pump that pawn up and he'd truly be
winning in fact it might be better to
have a pawn that just give up the bishop
the rules of chess allows you to just
remove your own piece and then stick the
pond there if only that would be a good
deal I think for black but he can't
so what has now happened is we got rook
c4 pawn takes pawn tags and black has a
simple notion he wants to move the
bishop and then put the pawn on c3 and
if unless white can find a way to stop
that the game's open so let's look at
the obvious way to at least try to stop
it is rook d7 say King age six
rook c7 but the bad news is rook e8
again on the dark squares it's too much
so at least a superficial glance says
that this was a nice exchange sacrificed
by jewel and really big Mick when you
get to this situation you might as well
try to trap the guy with Bishop c4
because now that the bishops here if you
don't do anything
jewels just gonna say hello and stick
the rook on e one and it'll never go
away there's not a situation what the
bishop is now obviously entrenched on c3
so beautiful game by jewel from a
position where look at the where did we
see Knight takes g6 just cuz you're old
doesn't mean you're creating not crazy
you know yeah every coat i takes d6 and
i know big Mick and I know Joel they one
problem you have as an old guy is you
kind of enjoy chess so much that you
just start sitting there as if you're
writing a novel you know you're just
thinking way too long about the business
and you got to just like be like
Geoffrey you know just move this move
and you don't think about it so long all
right let's go back and look at Mel Kumi
oh yeah can wecan yeah look at actually
at Group B yeah there's a game team or
garea versus Eugene Pearl's time oh yeah
it's really interesting looking because
there's a passed pawn on either side of
the board yeah and well Black has really
advanced now but I don't know if it
makes a difference well this is like our
clinic day on the bishops of opposite
color endgame isn't it right I want to
say this is a very interesting position
from the get-go let me just show you
that this
sure that we got here there was I
believe it's the tall Botvinnik 1960
match we're kind of similar structure
happened four by Vinick basically
laughed tall out of town was with a set
up kind of like with Eugene makes with
just putting everything on the light
squares and saying you can't do anything
what ended up happening there was tall
found a trick and then got through and
you can feel it like that's what garea
is playing for here so black is very
solid and your pawns on e4 and f3 are a
little bit hokey but white is the one
with chances for tricks if he can get
them but it's hard because the bishop on
f1 is running into a wall of white pawns
that are just going to be in his face
forever and you'd never really want to
commit the pawn on e4 either taking or a
five because then you have no juice left
in the position to do anything and black
with his Knights wants to dance on you
with like what we see in the game I
think 97 96 so this all went down b5 and
there's other plans here I'm sure for
black but what is lien tell peril steins
is an all guy fulfilling an old dream
which is put of your pawns in the
opposite color of your opponent's
unopposed light square pose bishop which
in this case is the light square bishop
and use your beautiful bishop to be have
all the pawns in all of the different
colors so he can roam around and now
it's going to turn into a mess but
notice Knight b6 is the only way to make
progress but it allows Bishop b5 and
here we get it just starts turning into
a mess because you know think about it
in a position like this you kind of want
to be the guy who's jumped out of the
airplane because you're gonna want to
find some tricky move to open black up
and so it really is an opportunist
scheme here for white where both white
and black need to black is trying to
prevent the opening of the position and
slowly improve his position giving
attack on the king and white is trying
to pop black open like a screw look at
that
bang it's my friend Udeid who go who
bites first look at that oh and now it's
turned him to miss and I'm not sure I
that if I was black I'd be a little
upset with that development it's
probably fine but I didn't really want
to all it did was it open things up
alright huge mess Timur has no problem
having his King open like this and now
we're just in messed territory
we're in pure maths territory I would
say black shouldn't lose and maybe it
should be a draw but in a practical
level with this little time remain well
they're gonna hit move four to get a
little bit more time but the game's
gonna go on on a practical level
someone's probably going to win right
because there's too much dynamic stuff
going on it's also the case that these
pawns it's gonna be hard for teamwork to
really advance them effectively and the
problem for white is orb excuse me for
black is this is pretty well guarded but
imagine if the bishop does a trick like
Bishop e3 g1 that can be annoying right
or if he got his King involved that
would be annoying
so there's definitely plants for both
sides and while black is trying to do
all that he has to be careful that white
doesn't get say a5 a6 in right that
would be a white stream if he can
achieve that
so the the H coupon is of no concern
right now oh it's definitely a long-term
concern we're not gonna advance it yet
but yeah white needs to be careful right
yeah no this is double-edged I'm not
sure I guess I'd rather be black but I'm
not sure it's better here you know
Maurice would probably just be like oh
it's a dead draw zeroes yeah so anyways
I think that's gonna be exciting thank
you for reminding me about that game us
watching that earlier and yeah you
better be careful Jesse he might be
watching this they might bust in here at
any second with this computer I'll tell
you how it is one of my worst fears is
to be confronted with a Reese's computer
Joel's physician looks beautiful over
here
well check in and that but it looks
winning Nikolas of course one oh let's
look at your game that you draw it drew
us to cavil is Billy against a lemur on
D let's look at what happened when after
we left so it was checked with the Queen
King G to check and then black said I
want more could if it looks like they
had a chance to just take a draw but he
said no I want more I'm not sure who's
better I'm more afraid I'm just gonna
get made at his way but I'm not sure
who's better because in position like
this
if white improves his position with
things like h4 and b4
there's no reason why white should be
worse here but a pawn was just snipped
so that's at least a reason for some
optimism okay I don't know what's gonna
happen there and all Emer on D is one of
the one of the one of the higher scores
in the B group right right a lemur on D
right now is two and a half out of four
so he's tied for third right now and
let's take a look at the Battle of
Armenia over here with Andrea Xeon and
Jaco bein
and you know this is again one of these
45 positions to start it off like this
we're gonna see a lot more of this stuff
and first glance you know the the rook
on g4 it's like the guy in the tennis
match who rushes the net so if the rook
doesn't produce something he's going to
regret being way over there but the
reason for optimism here for white is
that his King has more pawns in front of
it and that's a good long-term advantage
and these pawns aren't really going
anywhere so just on a superficial
analysis I'd rather be white here but
it's pretty complicated yeah so let's
head back oh it's gone it's gone gone
Loco here so let's look go back to this
position here's the move maybe I'll ask
the players about later I don't really
know why g3 was played it seems like if
I'm black I don't know really what I'm
doing and maybe you know Malcolm ian has
a complete and a sense of what he was
doing but I didn't and g3 really says to
me Oh f4 might do some stuff because
here it comes and then white has to
start worrying about FG have to worry
about f3 all this stuff and in time
pressure it's gonna get pretty crazy g4
happened and that's a concession that's
not something that he wanted to do age 5
g v f3 all remember how calm it was just
a little while ago they just go back and
see how calm it with oh look at this
column nice position we have instead we
got this business f3 now once the g3
pawn was well once the Jeep on was on
three it had to keep pushing right I
mean because of the the f-bomb or no no
I think I think casada must have not
seen how strong say yeah as i said i
didn't understand g3 I didn't understand
why to do it if I was going to move any
of the pawns it would have been I would
have played say f3 that would have been
my dogmatic
put them all in light squares make him
play f4 when it's not dangerous but the
second you play f4 now black has a lever
to open the position and also to play f3
himself g4 is the move of a man who's
not happy with life he's not happy life
and he's definitely not happy if he
plays g5 because now his King is simply
open f3 king h1 rook f7 the point of
three is not going anywhere anymore
rook III rook e8 what does black one he
wants to play like Queen b6 and / Queen
b3 so one interesting question
maybe we'll ask him it's like why didn't
you do say Bishop e5 and one answer
right here well it's complicated
this is one of the complicated questions
but maybe even rookie five I don't know
if that's true but that would be an idea
anyway so what do you is case out of
thinking of after his move Queen b3 to
retreat the knight to be - something
wrong happened and the other thing
that's interesting is that in this
position you know before no comeon was
babysitting the e5 point right in this
position though he says he's found a
tactic to deal with any kinds of takes
on e5 I don't even immediately know what
they are but I know they're there right
otherwise he wouldn't have played work
fsm rookie 3 happened and casada says
you're right I can't take I can't take
there and now the storms going to come
if you can't take right I'm going to
start building up and things like Queen
h3 and rook h4 in the air which are very
hard to deal with in a time pressure
that we now have brewing and let's let's
stay with this game for a second because
it's getting really hot
rook g1 Queen e6
and it almost feels like maybe the
intention was to play that move but he
decided he couldn't do it maybe I guess
now maybe he wants night III rook f7
there's a lot about this game I don't
understand I'm just gonna be honest
about that I feel you could be honest I
don't understand a lot of it against 33
h4 I don't understand anything
of this game nothing they're both in
hectic time trouble and maybe Maurice
would say this is a terrible game
because they've clearly made several
mistakes even though I don't understand
anything here I know that if we turned
the computer on the computer would say
several mistakes were made so I have no
idea what's going on casada is in the
lucky position of having three minutes
to make the next five moves and makuu
man only has 50 seconds remember chess
fans if you want to join us us chess
champs calm and we have under winter
chess classic click on live and if you'd
like to watch the game like we're seeing
it turn the chess engine off it is a
that is a component of chess 24 you can
turn that off so that little thermometer
doesn't work we do have a result we
don't have to jump to it immediately
just let you know that the Armenian
gaming group B is a draw o the friends
the friends the friends lots of things
happening here because it's you know
they got to move so fast
rook b1 I don't understand what they're
doing they're just kind of going back
and forth and that is the position that
we got where one move to making it till
time control I am not sure what's
happening
very hard position to judge I don't
think given from where black came from I
don't think he should be upset but it's
weird to think about because this whole
thing really arose with the critical
decision to play f5 you know I heard
this interesting interview with Sam
Franklin earlier today and he was just
talking a little bit and he said you
know he wrote this book about pawns and
he said basically my book was about the
fact that pawns can't go backwards yep
right and f5 is a really criminal thing
where there's no I don't see any need
for him to do it right he could do he a
very old man thing here and played
things like rook on f8 to somewhere f6
Bishop f8 you're fine you're doing fine
but the second you play f5 then all of
these pieces can come to life like the
knight and the rook and I don't
understand anything then of what
happened the dream of the f5 though is
precisely this kind of thing where at
least we start some drama this is like
the King's Indian players little
tactical game that they like to play
with you here and some kind of accident
can happen to the white king it could
also happen to the black King so heart
hard for me to judge that one let's
check in with Ray to see if he is
winning as I thought he was and maybe
I'm just wrong about that I've been
wrong about a lot of stuff let's go to
the position where we left off I liked
rook d5 here so that when they check us
were at least hitting e5 but this
happened
and then that happened and surprisingly
black it's surprising to me anyway black
has a little bit of juice in this
position where a problem is going to be
this pawn because the pawn on h3 is very
strong
I think Kasparov is famous for saying
like the pawn on h3 is worth two pawns
in a position like this you know you can
imagine if that pawn on h2 goes the pawn
h3 is very valuable f5 is of course the
thought for black here and maybe even g4
is something that white wants to
consider would be one first would be to
6 and now f5 so it looks like Robson has
allowed himself to become a little bit
passive here from this position where
I'm gonna I don't know you know you guys
can check out the computer but I thought
here white has to definitely be better
maybe a move like rook d5 [ __ ] and then
I want to use the the d3 Square honestly
to move my king to I guess the point of
rook d3 was that on 94 we don't want the
night to have access to this square but
king d1 is passive and rook B to passive
and there must have been some problem
with d4 that I don't understand because
now this just looks good for black very
pleasant all of a sudden
and white now finally plays g4 in a bit
of desperation I'm gonna say and maybe
this is enough to hold the balance but
this is frightening stuff I think the
intention is something like this if King
g5 White's gonna maybe try this move to
try to get counter play with rook g8
still a mess oh it looks like to me like
black should find some way to be better
because even if I say it's your move
buddy and you go I'm a you know rook
check I have King at five there's all
kinds of plans for me here
Knight of three maybe g3 maybe some
improvement with the rook terrifying
situation and now Shimano has the better
look I I honestly as a chess fan you
know let me tell you skies a story you
know we we people who do some chess
coaching or just chess fans watching the
youth in America come up we all have our
favorites as to who we think is gonna be
the next one right 2007 around there I
was like ray ropes he's the one a lot of
people thought that yeah I mean you know
he could still be he can Sam Shanklin
also improved at a later time and this
tournaments so sad for me because I feel
like what you just had this great
position doesn't get any better than
that now he's suffering but anyways I've
been wrong about several people I was
wrong about Shanklin I was wrong about
Nakamura so I don't have the greatest
greatest track record right now I really
like this kid a Christopher Wu yeah he's
come to the club right anyways maybe
helped you affect it sue so anyways yeah
it's it's so hard to make it you know
and wrote vrai is now in the high twenty
six hundred and one brutality is like
with Jean coming and they're saying
Dominguez might switch federations so he
might even even with the high 2600
rating he might not make the team even
an alternate anymore that's how strong
the US has suddenly become right right
anyway story over it's a good story
let's take let's take a look at what's
going on here let's go back to my
favorite gay male Kumi and game to see
what's going on then we have to check in
when there's a couple others so the dust
is settled a little bit and we're at
move 40 and rook takes G for us just
happened
I'm gonna guess rook takes G for is
going to come and arguably white is just
totally fine here because the knight on
e3 is covering everything the knight on
b4 is arguably shut out all right
interrupt yeah there will be no
skydiving today because your good friend
Eugene pearl Stein has one with black
against team or garea thoughts all right
let's take a look at how that happened
if we I don't know you know we're coming
to the end of a show but if we can get
him down here might be worth talking to
talk to Eugene yeah just for a short a
little bit sure we can let's see how
this went H to rook e4 now that and this
is the kind of position where you don't
want to do any skydiving you know you
wanna you want to mellow it on down and
find some way to push that a part so
rookie for leaving the baseline charging
the net doesn't feel right rook d5 I'm
gonna guess he missed that one in fact
that was right I move 40 so that's a
move 40 blunder that our skydiver
suffered in general keep your key yeah
it's like you're playing tennis from the
baseline keep up there buddy keep from
there don't move him off the baseline
whack you lost an important poem
snip snap that's game yep
that's that's it now move 40 blender for
those of them those viewers you don't
know yeah it just indicates that because
it's right before the second time
control right next time at it you have
the lowest amount of time this you're
most likely to blunder yeah it's a
crushing weight early but then you have
a whole bunch of time to look at your
mistake isn't that great yeah and you
got your friends to tell you about it
you can rewatch our broadcast and you
can listen to us talk about it too
yes yeah it's a brute Maurice comes in
with this computer and will yell at you
it's gonna become a reoccurring theme of
this show perhaps yeah okay what
happened to Mel cumin what's going on oh
I mean it's crazy
a game we haven't talked about them for
a while we need to do it though is the
sassy game we left this and saucy we
said I said looked better the first
glance it looks like a mess but in
general the person with the two bishops
wants the mess so just with that in mind
it's understandable
what happened white is pushing for
counter play maybe let's go back a
little bit see how this all happened
alright I'm gonna take a little bit of a
leave are you nice okay total mess that
we have here and that's pretty well our
current situation and right the pawn on
h6 will go and it's a question of
whether how powerful our b-pawn can
become and how powerful our bishops will
be a bummer for saucy is that whenever
b3 happens then Knight c4 can come and
really do a lockdown on the B 2 square
so something like that yeah so that's
hard
Eugene's just joined us here we're gonna
ask him about his game so I'm gonna pull
it up and then
yeah we'll get some well I'll ask him a
couple naive questions so here we go and
let's start kind of towards the
beginning design a thing Bishop f4 and I
assume somewhere around here you guys
were just playing chess at an early
stage yeah I mean he just decided to
just do after me with everything he's
got yeah trying to dig in it's kind of
funny that though that like do you think
he was copying what you did against Oh
what I did against big Mick yeah oh that
was tame what I just he was really going
after me with cows along and everything
but in my did you slightly similar and
then you played Knight B fibers yeah and
then I played 9 f3 h3 and ran off quiet
positional game right it wasn't going
for quiet h4 yeah that's not a quiet
line hates for I mean I have to play h5
otherwise well no he may just play by
himself right and this was an
interesting moment where he played the
knight of 3 and so I was thinking he may
try to play Knight e5 at some point
mm-hmm so I wasn't sure if Bishop g4 is
the correct approach I like what you did
I think it just solid yeah very solid
and at some point you're just gonna take
the thing right put all your pawns in
the light squares that was my plan yeah
so I thought what he did is very
controversial now right maybe I've got
the structure wrong but you can help me
there's a game in the bought vinick tall
match of 1960 where tall also allows
this kind of structure oh you mean in
the Cairo yeah yeah a to G takes f 3
yeah and we get this kind of thing and
it's like White's not breaking through
and in that game call swindles I think
could draw yeah but he was busted I
think I think he was probably at least
positionally busted yeah although here I
think it's like he's got the bishop pair
my king is very difficult for me to
Castle so I think this is better version
than the tall one well right but this is
weird thing it's like the bishop pair is
cool but if his bishop on f1 is hitting
rocks right the that's not so cool so I
want to commend you here because this
was really dogmatically
you did the next couple yeah I know the
barrel stays just putting everything on
light squares you'll see him building a
rock he's building a rock wall here so
II for I think is consonant with what he
wants to attach to play for you but one
bummer right for white is if you take
sits back if you can play five yeah so
now we just have to sit there and
maintain attention right right so yeah I
would rather be black here yeah King bee
want to think is good here you have some
questions about how to proceed a six
let's call that the height of dogmatism
sure I don't know wait and see it but if
you want to play b5 is their recent
notches to do it immediately yeah maybe
I can play right away I just thought a
six gives me more options but because I
want to play six at some point because I
can't play be fine before it but maybe
beef I was better just I thought with
you kind of like in the game you want to
do maybe you have to worry about it but
you also have to worry about it when you
play a six I mean it doesn't help you
promote b5 right well the problem was a
six I have the seat 65 option that's
what I see because with the early b5 he
can take on g5 I don't have the CB mmm
CD file option okay let's show our fans
that so if we go for caveman so this
right absolves you from some of the
claims of Doc Rios on my part if Mediate
v5 and I have to calculate D yeah
Edie now idiots of course controversial
cuz now White's and Elise don't know how
like the rookie one is the first
question well Ricky well done king of
faith King G that run away maybe well I
I mean I just figured that's something
you to at least be afraid maybe can
Bishop d6 first I'm a little bit scary
though this my king never maybe you
should be scared yeah I mean maybe night
of faith but then Bishop age three well
he's gonna do with a bishop yes but but
somehow it just feels to loosening I
don't know feels like there has to be Oh
a night of faith Knight takes b5 I'm
even oh yeah that's not let's show that
one that's nice that would be a skydiver
I didn't want to do what they are
assuming that on this guy I don't even
know if it works but you know it's still
it's still something that he probably
just some somewhere yeah
Milo alright so there we go a six this
is the full dogmatism I like it
and yeah so in order for you to make
progress over there on the left side
entangled somehow yeah and you have to
allow his Bishop to e5 yeah I didn't see
anything oh well yeah you could have a
castle I guess yeah but I just felt I'm
castling into the attack yeah castle was
my option as well but yeah I just
thought that I want to keep the key 1ea
to have ruiji it as an option I maybe I
can Castle queenside at some point I'll
just leave the king of the center so I
got nine mystical interestin it's funny
in this position I am very prejudiced
against white I don't like the bishop on
d3 I don't like the night and I feel
like one curious thing that I was just
as a feeling I was like Eugene at some
point you play Bishop f8 and bring it
over to start nail yeah I was
considering the ship of faith here as
well as yeah but honestly like if he
doesn't meet me positionally he is just
much worse if I can like save guard my
king right so I think you just go has to
go for some direct attack and maybe he
has some I don't think he's like worse
but at the same time like I didn't see
any decisive blow you don't think why
it's worse here I mean I mean long-term
he is worse but yeah right now I still
have to untangle okay and he has the
time right so so here we go Bishop e5 I
wasn't a huge fan of Bishop h6 I like
Bishop h6 section Andrew G I thought
that's pretty solid yeah you're doing
some real old man stuff yeah and that's
can get faith really because here it's
actually tactically has to play Queen e1
because of Queen e2 don't be for there
is a small problem with the knight on c3
so he has to leave the square open if he
plays f4
then maybe I have before 92 and then the
Epona same right so somehow like
tactically he's not able to because he
was play a four and five and just right
open up the center
so I think that's why key to Quincy five
which i think is already like a
concession yeah but I mean what else to
do for him well I could tell here that
when he played that fort at some point
he wants the sky dive you with that by
that with it yeah yeah Queen e7 f5 is
coming so right see I knew that I have
to get out yeah and somehow I'm already
pretty confident here like I calculated
that in all the lines my king escapes
like if he plays a five I can just take
it and like this I mean yeah it's like
your position but the scrunch Eugene I'm
feeling a little uncomfortable with the
scrunch over here right there okay so
here we go f3 yeah and I thought my next
one was pretty strong actually okay FD
so once I gave it a five bishop then my
my life improves dramatically and your
Bishop on h6 so here he thought for a
long time he was probably calculating an
f5 suck right but I just take it you
just take it yeah so he says check to
the miserable King yeah III yeah no I'm
pretty happy because now my king is safe
yeah ninety-four is coming and he missed
nicéphore shot I think and after that
it's kind of one-sided game well you
know it's funny with night c4 because
one thing that's weird about it to me
was that when you do Knight c4 at least
he can open the game a little bit for
his Bishop yeah but one of the bishop is
gonna get taken right either the g3 was
at u6 o and I'm attacking like black is
pretty happy right because my king is
safe what about this for the natural
what about a dogmatic I mean my
dogmatism here is just like maybe even
Bishop f8 oh yeah bishop of faith is
more positional approach I think nothing
wrong with that because I feel like long
term he's just toast right and Knight
Sephora well well you can I wasn't sure
what was happening later but well so
let's go to that night see that felt
right so what he did is you do all these
scrunchie moves and then you go then are
you at some point I got a scar that yeah
yeah it's off is a castle right so yeah
attack all right five looks like a good
idea
and before just asking for it I mean I
didn't really calculate to them like I
could have played 93 than before but I
thought before opening up files can't be
bad for me okay
so it has to kind of go for this yeah
I'm sure I could have played better than
what I allowed in the game
but I kind of played natural moves and
we're getting into time like especially
me I was getting to time pressure mode
right so I just wanted to play it safe
here with 96 I'm sure there are other
moves like rook c8 was interested in
yeah I don't know B Athens King game one
and then try because maybe what happened
the bummer here is Wendy's establishes
the bishop on b5 he has chances to slow
your yeah maybe we need King a1 Bishop
g7 yeah she will just wake a nap yeah
they'll just yeah
Dominator you working well right and
then also part of what Knight b6 feels
like is you're trying to stop d5 but of
course once you get the bishop on no d5
was never a threat yeah so oh yeah I'm
sure what I did is not best but I think
it's the most practical approach just go
for the F pawn right and I've been
taught with opposite castling opposite
color bishops is always good for the
attacker yeah that's true and I'm the
one who's attacking for free and the HP
one is weak so block is definitely
better but okay at least he's not
getting made it alright listen to what
he just said that was a lot of people
don't appreciate that you know I get so
many people in there like Oh opposite
colored bishop it's gonna be a drawing
yeah give me a break
so the thing he just said I think it's
really important once he gets an
initiative on the dark squares black
white is helpless helpless helpless he's
gonna dominate yeah so he has to trade
Queens which he did later in the game
but at a cost so I'm just gonna take the
point at this point yeah thank you very
much and the eighth point is not as
relevant cuz his King is still exposed
although I have to watch out for if I
play he's like some some sneaky ideas
there so this was an interesting
position that we get yeah he goes
directly for the end game which I
thought is good for me because my H
bonus so far let's look at this so you
felt okay yeah you felt what you were
better winning oh definitely better I
mean winning name is
a little bit too strong of a word but
I'm probably black as closer to wind and
whites you draw let's put it that way
because he can't push the April his king
is gonna get exposed he's only playing
as bishop she's six and then try to push
the pawn right but then Bishop g6 and
then I'm using all these Tempe ideas on
the how the before square all right let
me just play devil's advocate King c4
yep so now what's his threat either a
five-way I guess a fine all right yeah
Kings before I thought he has deployed
during the game and then maybe Bishop d6
to get the before square so this is six
and then I'm gonna start invading or
maybe a five first think I would play a
five and then you're gonna check me
write a five check Bishop c6 check King
back and a fornicator of them that's
something I'm not sure about you know
yeah that I was concerned during the
game about this or oopsie a check Bishop
c6 and now
all right I have this interesting idea
to go for checkmate
rugby for Chuck King c3 and there's
double the B file
let me just put it on a light square I
don't know why oh it doesn't matter yeah
I was gonna double so and then the idea
is I'm gonna if he plays like a six Ruby
three checking before Ruby for me so
those kind of a cute idea I had second
she roots of the bishop concealed
attackers yeah and his bishop is totally
out of play if he if he cannot get the
point far and I can always stop with
okay three later like how was he gonna
untangle that's interesting and the King
cannot hide one of one because the h1 so
where's the king going yeah I feel like
if he manages to trade a pair of rooks
here's a nice variation I just came up
with for you you you checked them in
struck first yeah and then you just get
here and I don't think I'll go to c3 but
if he goes here you say check to the
misérable King find them and then you
say check or that check we're rookie to
- yeah ugly - job - just game over yeah
that's the attack on the darts way yeah
so that's what I showed you in the game
that I'm just going for me
uh-huh and the eighth point is
irrelevant cuz this one's just six
doesn't participate okay and maybe it's
just yeah I love my before you we played
I don't know I it's interesting that
you're so confident in this musician but
okay and then let's just see what
happened in the game this looked to me
like a move 40 blunder well maybe he
knew he is lost and maybe he just
decided to kind of force things huh but
maybe he just didn't calculate you then
but this is in 1/35 my new favorite
metaphors you know when you got to be
careful when you rush the night right
you know he's rushed in the net here I
said of keeping the baseline yeah well
cuz ideas Bishop d6 f4 to cut the bishop
but he missed the shot
and now I think I'm just done with it I
mean he missed rook d5 probably yeah you
gotta be in bit
why that's what I mean by under yeah
okay so yeah very nice game that was
that's the first win right for me no
suckas there cuz I want Brown to yeah
that's right yeah so what do you got
plus one plus one though yeah yeah cuz
you moving over there arable van forest
yeah he uh yeah you know it's kinda know
that's one for is the other Greek one
okay sorry Theodore no that was I would
before we had him in here before it yeah
absolutely am a he's skydive today oh
yeah again oh yeah oh you wanna show you
the skydive move all right let's see and
he said he saw it in advance
oh my god and and and during the the
analysis you know what I said I said I
know he's I said Palestine told me he's
bluffing here to check out this movies
so he played d6 like a madman oh my god
and then and then he said he saw it to
this they did that movie am
wow that is and then he saw this he also
he said when he played d6 he saw there's
King g2 containing Mike Queen and if he
can take with Chuck but he doesn't care
yeah cuz the sepal injures Queens that
guy's a beast he's already got two games
for his best games collection although
my game I think he did bluff me a little
with that he played well up to them are
you G thank you for coming all right
Thank You Jesse
alright yeah we're gonna take a look at
some of the other games before we close
out our show here the famous a lemur on
D is getting he's Catholic evalee is not
a normal man he is a man determined to
fight and he might still find a mate
against white here
I guess I'd rather be black sure I'd
rather be black the bishop on f5 is
uncomfortable and of course the White
King is uncomfortable
and it was a big deal that keV allege
Billy could steal the pawn on h2 so this
game let's call it advantage black and
it's still gonna go on white of course
if he can play moves like b6 and
consolidate a little bit especially a
move like me even G for right now it is
to be a challenge for black to organize
an attack on the the King honestly with
g4 there's moves like actually rook e8
might come into play after g4 the
problem though in general for white for
black excuse me is that you can't really
play g6 to help your king and h6 the
bishops running it to but should be
winning for black all right welcome back
mr. Ben what is the outside world look
like out there well I think the outside
world is gearing up for the game two of
world chess champion tomorrow yeah yeah
you don't want to miss that I mean we
had a huge viewership number today
watching the event and rightfully so I
mean you can even though it's on another
continent you can you can feel it yeah
here in st. Louis and you can feel on
the the broadcast so for the record I
mean I don't know if we need to go
through the whole graphical process
again but Jan Yasir and Maurice hosting
the World Chess Champion right every day
that it's on two hours after the
beginning of the round the official
broadcast is at world chess calm but you
can see our coverage live at us chess
champs calm right where you're watching
this hopefully and that begins that
resumes tomorrow at 11 a.m. Central now
as far as this event we will be with you
at 3:30 p.m. Central right after the
world championship game so until then I
have to give a shout out to the world's
greatest production B team Tammy Hyde
working on two streams simultaneously
today Isaac Krantz graphics and audio
and our technical director is danny
Machuca so for Grandmaster Jessie cry my
name is Ben Simon we'll see you tomorrow
first World Championship at 11 a.m.
Central and then our coverage of the
Winter Classic at 3:30 so long from the
show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you